it shattered the peace and threatened
years of stability Sunday's bombing on
estaclaus Street in the center of
Istanbul brought back memories of a
turbulent past
[Music]
there is Defiance crowds have returned
the authorities in Turkey are blaming
their longtime enemy the outlawed
Kurdish group The pkk which has denied
any role but some believe there was a
political message
this can negatively affect the upcoming
elections terrorism will cause tension
on the election process and voters in
the Southeast will be intimidated the
Democratic process will be taken hostage
the southeast is Turkey's Kurdish
Heartland where the state is fighting a
years-long conflict with the pkk it's
also where the majority of the Kurdish
population lives
their vote will be important if not
decisive in the presidential and
parliamentary elections next June that's
why the largest pro-kurdish political
party the hdp is being courted not just
by the opposition in a major break from
the past the governing act party met
members of the country's third largest
party
for a long time now
our party and its partner in the
alliance MHP have been denouncing any
contact made with HTTP because of their
ties with the terrorist organization pkk
and you know they were criticizing the
opposition about having implicit
dialogue with this party
Sunday's attack may make it harder to
continue that dialogue as part of an
election strategy
the MHP is calling for the closure of
hdp describing its members as
separatists and terrorists the bombing
has created a new political atmosphere
months ahead of an election many say
could be president erdogan's toughest
battle he has lost some support the
economy is in trouble and while the
government has been proud of its
campaign to eliminate what it considers
the pkk security threat at home and the
neighboring Iraq and Syria further
attacks like Sundays could undermine
that
erdogan's critics see an opportunity for
the governing party to Rally nationalist
support ahead of the vote but for now
security is what is on the minds of many
here
al-jazeera Istanbul